de la case en paille à la case en tôle
des premiers temps de la colonisation
jusqu'au début du xviiie siècle
esclave et colons bâtissent des maisons
à l'aide de troncs et de branches
couvertes de feuilles récupérer dans les
savanes où les forêts qui les entoure
ces paillote sont les premières cases de
lille au 19e siècle aux feuilles de va
quoi et de latanier s'ajoute la paille
de canne à sucre et sel de vétiver les
paillotes sont alors le mode d'habitat
le plus répandu dans les îles et les
plus éloignés mais aussi dans les camps
des sucreries et à la périphérie des
filles ces maisons précaires contraste
avec les demeures bourgeoises les usines
et les édifices publics bâti en
matériaux plus nobles régulièrement
reconstruite après un cyclone les
paillotes constituent toutefois
l'essentiel de l'habitat populaire
réunionnais jusqu'au milieu du xxème
siècle ces petites cases ne sert alors
qu'à dormir
le boucan ou cuisine se trouvant quant à
lui à proximité dans les années 1950 les
tôles de récupération les fûts
métalliques déroulé et autres ustensiles
recyclé font leur apparition dans ses
constructions de fortune
seul perdure la structure et la
charpente en bois de jadis sur laquelle
on vient clouer les feuilles de métal la
case en paille et devient case en tôle
ces plaques de fortune sont peu à peu
remplacées par des tôles ondulées
importés par les grossistes en matériaux
si de nombreuses case en tôle subsiste
encore de nos jours dans les zones
rurales
elles ont tendance à disparaître
progressivement en zone urbaine avec le
développement de l'habitat social en
mode collectif